camila and i are staying in an apartment
in new york city for the very first time
alone
and making eggs and trying to figure out
how to use a keurig
normal things you know this is really
cool to just be like a 21 year old guy
shawn netflix documentary in wonder
dropped
monday giving fans an inside look at the
now 22 year old's relationship with
camila cabello
when you're first dating someone that
you've been friends with for a really
long time and it just feels like
oh my god like we're we're kissing now
now
et's breaking down the nine must-see
moments between the love birds
starting with this we're in new york
and my son comes on the radio or
something and some of the fact
comes up that that's about her and i'm
like yeah it's about her yeah it's about
you and i'm like everything is about you
it's always there
they've always been about you she knows
what do you mean i'm like like they're
all about you
like every song i've ever wrote and like
rhyming off the songs and like treat you
better
like like all these songs she's like oh
my gosh she's literally had no idea
this whole time i thought she like knew
yeah that's shawn dishing on the moment
he told his girlfriend that
all of his songs past and present
are about her i don't think that i'm
gonna be able to write songs that really
do it justice
that can really capture the things and
the feelings with her
i think it's like when you see a moon or
stars and you try and take a photo of it
with your iphone
and then you just can't it just doesn't
look good
and you're like it's not supposed to be
captured you know
it's just supposed to be for us um
not meant to be captured swoon much
thank you so much and he dishes on when
they first met
camila she was in fifth harmony and we
were both opening
my very first tour ever and she was the
act after me i was the first in the
lineup with the shortest set and then
they went on
five years ago man as for camila
she's all over the documentary and talks
about her first impression of sean
he was so super like
hyper focused on what he was doing i
never saw him that whole tour
he was like constantly going in and out
of his bus like playing guitar writing
songs with jeff
[Music]
you know i thought he was cute but i was
like he's he's doing other stuff so
whatever but all that changed after they
saw each other backstage at a taylor
swift concert
and wrote a song together she's amazing
like super talented as songwriter like i
was so
no i mean i've never worked with the
actual songwriter who i clicked with as
well as her
yeah you know the one
after that we like spent a lot of time
with each other because we had this song
together and we like did a whole jingle
ball tour together
and that's really when the
saga started
i really liked him
[Music]
i guess he liked me but
i don't really know and while shawn may
have taken his
sweet time to come around he says that
during the in between
they built a crazy good friendship for
the past like four years just being
friends and not being able to see each
other
very often to finally being able to be
together
she was always there to look out for me
as a human being
she's got my back and i think that's
what your partner's for
sweet right i've always loved him he
says they just get each other
yesterday we were watching videos of us
when we were like
16. we we both got so caught up in it
and we looked at each other and we're
like
i don't feel good because we were taken
right back to that insecure
unsure 15 year old and i just felt like
wow she really understands that feeling
good
and we just looked at each other and
we're like well we feel weird right now
don't we
and she's like yeah we do and i'm like
i'm so happy you know why
because i don't know if i could explain
this very well to other people
camila shows up for all his big shows
like his concert in his hometown toronto
and his last stop on the 105 show tour
how is it to put to perform that without
sean
it's lonely i don't like it
i want it i want it back and when she's
not there
sean wears her heart on his sleeve
no seriously he wears a hoodie with her
face
all up on it look at this look at the
sweater
camilla oh my god my girlfriend do you
know about her
no i don't sean